mehrere schwarze löcher im zentrum der
milchstraße das wäre wirklich neue rund
um das supermassereiche schwarze loch im
zentrum unserer milchstraße kreisen
weitere kleinere aber trotzdem
supermassereiche schwarze löcher so die
these der reihe nach mit hilfe des
entscheides stationierten zwölf meter
apex teleskop wurde jetzt die kartierung
des bisher größten teils der südlichen
milchstraße abgeschlossen
die neuen karten decken einen bereich
von 140 längen und drei breitengraden ab
das ist viermal so viel als alte
aufnahmen und die auflösung ist zudem
viel höher
die aufnahmen liegen im
submillimeterbereich das bezieht sich
auf die wellenlänge der gemessenen
strahlen diese aufgezeichnete strahlung
hatte eine wellenlänge von 0 87 mm zitat
atlas gaal hat uns eine neue sichtweise
auf das dichte interstellare medium
unserer eigenen galaxie ermöglicht der
milchstraße
die neue veröffentlichung der gesamten
durchmusterung eröffnet uns die
möglichkeit in diesem großartigen
datensatz nach neuen entdeckungen zu
suchen viele teams aus wissenschaftler
nutzen die atlas gaal daten bereits für
die planung von nachfolge beobachtungen
berichtet leonardo testi vom eso dem
european versand observatoriums gaal
steht übrigens für apex teleskop large
area service of the galaxy immer mehr
rätsel werden somit immer
leistungsfähigerer technik gelöst einem
sehr spannenden sind das nur glamour
radioteleskop in japan und duster
radioteleskop in chile auf die spur
gekommen
einen so genannten intermediären
schwarzen loch mit hilfe der teleskope
wurde eine gaswolke beobachtet deren
gase sich mit sehr unterschiedlichen
geschwindigkeiten bewegen
die vermutung ein weiteres super
massereiches schwarzes loch nahe dem
zentrum unserer galaxie
demnach gäbe es nicht nur ein super
massereiches schwarzes loch im zentrum
der milchstraße sondern darum herum
weitere sehr große die stück für stück
vom großen schwarzen loch im zentrum
aufgezogen werden das schwarze loch im
zentrum sagt gitarrist stern hat eine
masse von rund 45 millionen sonnenmassen
das jetzt vermutete intermediäre
schwarze loch von mehr
100 tausend sonnenmassen es wird
spannend wenn wir hier auf der erde
gravitationswellen registrieren
die vom zentrum der milchstraße
herrühren
wenn ein solches super massereiches
schwarzes loch in das schwarze loch im
zentrum unserer milchstraße stürzt auch
besonders an den aufnahmen aus dem
projekt atlas gaal ist dass sie das
kalte universum zeigen betrachtet man
die aufnahmen also zeigen sie regionen
mit materie in der galaxie die nur
einige dutzend grad über dem absoluten
nullpunkt liegen dass können gas und
staub seien mit den neuen aufnahmen
da wollen die wissenschaftler molekül
haufen besser untersuchen die auch
geburtsstätten von sternen sein können
was macht den südlichen teil der
milchstraße aber eigentlich so
interessant dass es der wissenschaft
solche neue möglichkeiten bietet in ihr
befindet sich das sogenannte galaktische
zentrum der milchstraße also genau der
ort wo sich das supermassereiche
schwarze loch sagt carius a stern
befindet uns leicht weitere kleinere
supermassereiche schwarze löcher wie
spektakulär das zentrum aussieht das
sehen wir gerade je detaillierter die
aufnahmen sind desto besser kann man die
strukturen der milchstraße erkennen in
sichtbaren licht sieht das ganze noch
wie ein großer chaotischer sternenhaufen
aus die neuen aufnahmen der sehr kurzen
wellenlängen ermöglichen uns jetzt aber
einen tieferen und strukturierten blick
in das galaktische zentrum zitat laska
liefert aufregende einblicke wo sich die
nächste generation sehr massereicher
sterne und haufen bilden kombinieren wir
dies mit beobachtung von plank erhalten
wir jetzt eine verknüpfung zu den
großflächigen strukturen riesiger
molekülwolken erläuterte merk serie vom
max planck institut für radioastronomie
in bonn
der satellit planck zeichnet die
kosmische hintergrundstrahlung auf und
kann jetzt mit seinen daten eine
ergänzung zum apex teleskop darstellen
in der asse pressemitteilung heißt es
die kombination der planck und apex
daten ermöglicht es astronomen strahlung
nachzuweisen
die über einen großen himmels bereich
verteilt ist und daraus den anteil
dichten gases in immer im inneren der
galaxie ab
schätzen ja was auch immer in der
milchstraße verborgen liegen könnte also
bald aufgedeckt werden und das könnten
zum beispiel noch mehr
supermassereiche schwarze löcher seien
aufgedeckt wurde über unsere heimat
galaxie übrigens ja schon so einiges
erst im januar diesen jahres haben
forscher des max-planck-instituts für
astronomie in heidelberg eine alters
karte von rund 100.000 roten riesen
erstellt das ist eine bestimmte sterne
kategorie sie bestimmten also das alter
der sich in der milchstraße befindenden
körper und konnten somit die ausgangs
richtung des wachstums bestimmen die
ältesten sterne fanden sie nahe des
zentrums und die jüngeren eher am rand
der galaxie schlussfolgerung das
wachstum richtet sich von innen nach
außen gerade mal einen monat zuvor wurde
eine weitere erkenntnis über die
milchstraße wissenschaftlich
nachgewiesen die erkenntnis über die
wasserstoff verteilung innerhalb der
galaxie die wissenschaftler des
effelsberg service kurz pages
veröffentlichten im dezember 2015 eine
aufnahme die die bisher genaueste
wasserstoff verteilung der nördlichen
milchstraße zeigt zitat wer die
räumliche verteilung des wasserstoffs
kennt kann auch viel genauer auf die
tatsächliche leuchtkraft eines sterns
schließen ja das sagte damals jürgen
kerb vom argelander institut für
astronomie der universität bonn
neben der helligkeit der sterne können
experten mit der erkenntnis auch die
entstehung von sternen regionen aus dem
gas genauer erforschen und damit sind
wir wieder fast am anfang des videos den
neuen aufzeichnungen der südlichen
sternen entstehungs region wir werden
also bald mehr über die südliche seite
der milchstraße wissen und damit auch
mehr über das galaktische zentrum
sensationell oder nicht den daumen nach
oben vergessen aber nur wenn euch das
video gefallen hat zur zeit hat man ja
wirklich das gefühl die wissenschaft
rast nur so davon was glaubt ihr werden
wir in naher zukunft da noch entdecken
habt ihr könnt sich irgendwas gelesen
oder erfahren oder eigene ideen
lasst uns darüber in den kommentaren
wissen ja und wenn ihr interessante
themen vorschläge habt dann machen wir
daraus natürlich auch videos heute gibt
es von mir mal wieder eine kleine
hörbuch empfehlung und ihr könnt es
kostenlos bekommen ich zitiere einfach
mal den ersten satz der inhaltsangabe
unsere galaktische heimat
sonnensystem in einem spital am der
milchstraße wird immer genauer erforscht
wenn ihr euch für das hörbuch
interessiert dann findet ihr in der
video beschreibung unseren link zum
hörbuch dort könnt ihr dann 30 tage
audible kostenlos testen und bekommt
auch noch das hörbuch geschenk also hört
mal rein ansonsten bis dann ein
vergesst nicht den kostenlosen abo
button zu drücken drücken also jetzt bis
dann bleibt dran